a scottish
moral philosopher of all people is the spiritual forefather
of capitalism adams in 1776 was the
first to recognize and describe the basic principle of the free
market economy
his main work the prosperity of
nations is still considered the bible
of capitalism
and in fact it was the holy book for
ten years most of the time
translated book of the earth
the theory of the invisible hand of
adams went like wildfire and
the whole world and is still the
heart of the capitalist market
model it measures generated the
magic formula of the free play of
supply and demand yes he also
delivered the philosophical
anthropological  justification for the
capitalist mode of production because
the human being is egotistical by nature
and concerned about his own interests
and it is precisely this natural
disposition that the market economy accommodates by
giving each of us the chance
to lose our prosperity in
the end soga uses this  r all
because everyone works
to improve their own quality of life
, as if guided by an
invisible hand, without
perhaps wanting it, they
also demand the well-being of the general public. there is
actually such a transformation of
egoistic energy into
social prosperity. how
does adam's market model work
smith you can really
let the economy run free capitalism is
natural to people the book
explains his astute theory in up to 60 minutes
and i also
tried to ask what is the use and the
discovery of suisse today
we have after the fall of
communism the  experienced the worldwide triumph of the
capitalist market model
but also the increasing crises of
capitalism must be seen
and discussed top politicians
bankers and business elites know
adams inside out but basically every person
who lives in the market economy should and we do
that today  almost everyone is familiar with the core idea
of smiths the m
chanism of the invisible hand is mu
h more than mere theor
it st
ll describes the heart chamber of the c
pitalist world it is
essential to know the basis of the socia
order in wh
ch we live